pour mon projet doctorale je m'intéresse
à la perception de la parole
particulièrement la multimodalité de la
parole de l'enfance vers l'âge adulte
dans la vie de tous les jours lorsqu'on
lorsqu'on communique on utilise des
informations qui sont auditive
on entend des sons les informations qui
sont visuels on voit les mouvements des
articulteurs l'élève dans ma joie mais
aussi des informations qui sont
propriétés petit donc ils font référence
au mouvement ressenti lorsqu'on parle
donc moi ce que je cherche à faire pour
ma thèse c'est de démontrer ou essaient
d'évaluer comment l'enfant peut utiliser
ces trois types d'informations là quand
il est tout jeune et comment il se
développe
marc lange a dit les résultats des
travaux comme les miens mais peuvent
venir enrichir nos connaissances
actuelles et ça aussi des répercussions
au plan des retombées clinique
je pense par exemple aux enfants qui ont
soit 1 troubles auditifs ou un trouble
visuel mais les intervenants peuvent
s'appuyer sur des recherches similaires
à main à la mienne pour construire leurs
intérêts leurs interventions et par
exemple soit un focus et sur les
modalités pour lesquels il ya peut-être
une difficulté ou alors sur celles qui
sont bien fonctionnel puis qui peuvent
permettre à l'enfant de compenser donc à
ces difficultés